[Applaudissements]
vous
moi ensemble nous avons une chance
incroyable
nous sommes en train d'assister à la
naissance d'un nouveau monde
alors bien sûr chaque jour
s'entrechoquent le meilleur et le pire
en ce moment mais quelle aubaine
incroyable d'être les témoins
privilégiés de ce moment dans ce
contexte je vais tenter de vous
expliquer comment notre regard sur le
monde change le monde et d'ailleurs je
vous invite dès maintenant à une petite
expérimentation je vous propose de poser
votre regard sur quelqu'un de ce set de
cette salle que vous ne connaissez pas
ça y est vous y êtes
alors maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe
que voyez vous dans cette personne
voyez-vous le positif ou le reste notre
regard at il été mécaniquement positif
ou bien négatif je propose de mettre ça
de côté on va y revenir tout à l'heure
la naissance de ce nouveau monde
s'accompagne de multiples transition
j'en retiens trois la transition
numérique qui a déjà tellement
bouleversé notre quotidien et dont nous
ne soupçonnions pas encore les nouveaux
impacts avec l'intelligence artificielle
le big data et la robotique la
transition écologique vital pour notre
espèce qui va nous ouvrir les portes de
l'économie régénérative et puis enfin la
transformation des organisations et
c'est le sujet que nous allons aborder
ensemble aujourd'hui durant 15 ans j'ai
été un patron d'entreprise classique en
2010 ma vie entière a changé je venais
de croiser le chemin des entreprises
libérer alors qu on appelle ça
entreprises libéré organique humaniste
responsabilisante 2.0 20.0 c'est pas
vraiment le sujet ce qui est important
c'est ce que nous tentons d'y faire
en l'occurrence conjuguées de notre
mieux la confiance et la liberté
à la clé des personnes plus engagé mieux
dans leur peau et une organisation plus
performantes
je ne résiste pas ce clin d'oeil
peut-être connaissez-vous comme moi
cette expression la confiance n'exclut
pas le contrôle
peut-être même l'utiliser vous de temps
en temps moi aussi je l'utilisé
longtemps longtemps jusqu'à ce que
j'apprenne que c'était lénine qui en
était l'auteur après je faisais moins
les fiers de l'entreprise libéré j'aime
ce terme
quoi de plus beau que la liberté
je propose aussi de mettre de côté les
raccourcis médiatiques entrepris sans
chef sans manager tout ça c'est pas du
tout la réalité de ce que nous y vivons
bien sûr le manager est là bien sûr le
patron là la seule chose c'est que leur
rôle est différent
à la manière du jardinier ils sont là
pour créer les conditions qui vont
permettre aux équipes de grandir de se
réaliser
pour mieux comprendre ce mouvement qui
fédère aujourd'hui des centaines
d'entreprises je me propose de partager
avec vous quelques uns des mécanismes à
l'oeuvre dans nos organisations et la
première chose c'est que nous partageons
un certain nombre de croyances
la première chose nous croyons à la
subsidiarité
ça veut dire que chacun dispose en lui
des ressources pour faire face aux
problématiques auxquelles il est
confronté
nous croyons à la puissance de
l'intelligence collective et le croyons
que la transformation de nos
organisations commencent par notre
propre transformation préalable
allons plus loin et je vous propose
trois clés trois clés de lecture
la première
robert rosenthal psychologue américain
confie un jour à ses élèves des rats
l'objectif leur faire traverser un
labyrinthe le plus possible le plus
rapidement possible la première équipe
reçoit des rats exceptionnel la seconde
des rats peu agile il les entraîne le
résultat arrive et c'est les rats
l'équipe de rats exceptionnelle qui va
gagner très haut la main l'épreuve en
réalité des rares ont été affectés de
manière totalement aléatoire et pour en
temps vous voyez le résultat
on constate donc très vite que
finalement le regard de l'accompagnateur
du coach du manager sur son équipe
impacte directement le résultat de
l'équipe
si le retard est positif et transcendant
c'est l'effet pygmalion
s'il est négatif s'il amène un
désengagement ça sera l'effet golem
l'expérience est renouvelée cette fois
ci dans une école de san francisco les
profs apprennent qu'un certain nombre de
leurs élèves ont des capacités
extraordinaires
en réalité les scientifiques
après avoir fait un passé un test de
cuillé aux enfants ont augmenté
artificiellement les notes pour certains
d'entre eux ils reviennent un an après
et là après avoir fait passer un nouveau
test de qi il rencontre que les qu'ils
se rendent compte que les enfants
d'autres les avait augmentés
artificiellement les résultats ont dans
la réalité augmentée de 5 à 25%
leur performance leur cuit les profs par
le regard par l'attention qu'ils ont
apporté aux élèves les ont aidés à se
révéler bienvenue dans le monde des
prophéties autoréalisatrices notre
regard sur les autres les changes
alors quelles conséquences pour nos
organisations
le deuxième lecture c'est mcgregor
douglas mc gregor professeur ou un
métier dans les essaims dans mes années
mcgregor nous explique dans son livre la
dimension humaine de l'entreprise que
derrière le modèle d'organisation
dominant et vous le savez comme moi
c'est l'organisation pyramidale
dernière le modèle d'organisation
dominant existe une croyance cette
croyance c'est que les gens n'aiment pas
travailler et qu'ils feront tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour l'éviter et c'est
pour ça qu'on va mettre des managers qui
vont expliquer aux gens ce qu'il faut
faire et si le boulot est bien fait
carottes pas bien fait
le bâton mcgregor nous révèle aussi
qu'il existe d'autres types d'entreprise
fondée sur d'autres croyances on y croit
ici que le travail est aussi naturel que
le repos le loisir ces entreprises vont
mettre l'humain en leur coeur et faire
place à la performance collective
ces entreprises deviennent plus agile et
sur le long terme plus performantes
alors résumons nous ici j'ai
l'organisation pyramidale
ici les organisations nouvelle si on
peut les appeler entreprises libéré on
est dans une logique de la performance
individuelle ici alors qu'ici dans la
logique de performance collective
ici on est dans la logique du pouvoir du
père le patron ici le pouvoir des pères
prs ici on fait tout pour réussir dans
la vie et il est talonné par des
symboles de pouvoir alors qu'ici on va
tenter de les gommer pour simplement
essayer de réussir sa vie
ici nous sommes dans une logique de
l'avoir alors qu'ici peut-être plutôt
dans une logique de naître donc s'il
regard du patron dans son organisation
est déficitaire dépréciative de l'autre
il va amener une spirale de
désengagement si par contre son regard
est appréciative positif s'il transcende
il va amener une spirale d'engagement
des équipiers soyons encore un peu plus
précis quelles sont précisément les
résultats et ça sera notre troisième clé
galope l'institut de sondage nous en dit
plus
avec son questionnaire qui s'appelle le
cul 12 ils vont casser en trois
catégories les personnes qui sont sondés
d'abord
les d'abord les engager les désengager
et les activement désengager les engagés
quels sont ils
ils sont enthousiastes heureux de faire
le boulot on aimerait avoir que des gens
comme ça
les désengager ce dont la vraie vie
commence en dehors des bulgares des murs
dans l'entreprise on les repère assez
facilement cela comment ça va comment
lundi aussi les allez bon courage
et puis les 3e catégorie les activement
des engagés ce qu'on pourrait être
considérée comme toxique pour
l'organisation et bien connaissez vous
ces chiffres au niveau mondial au niveau
mondial le pourcentage des salariés
considérés comme engagée uniquement 13%
à l'opposé les activement désengager les
toxiques de leurs organes de
l'organisation 24% et donc 63 ans milieu
imaginez un bateau avec huit rameurs ça
veut dire qu'il y en a un qui rament
fort dans un sens 5 qui font des petits
coups drame être comme ça et de kara mal
envers les entreprises pyramidale avec
des résultats comme ça démontre-t-elle
leurs performances je pense qu'on peut
au moins légitimement se poser la
question
alors finalement comment ça marche dans
ces organisations différentes isag est
le coauteur de liberté et compagnie ce
best seller il avait tu sa théorisé la
le leadership libérateur il nous
explique que le rôle du patron dans ce
nouvelle organisation est en fait celui
du jardinier et comme le jardinier
garantie doit garantir l'accès à l'eau
la lumière et les nutriments pour ses
plantes
ici le patron doit garantir trois choses
la première c'est de répondre le
sentiment d'égalité intrinsèque faire en
sorte que que j'ai 20 ans 40 ans que 60
ans dans la boîte que je sois mécano
comptables informaticiens ou ingénieurs
peuvent
art je puisse partager ce que je ressens
ce que je pense auprès du collectif
parce que ça va nourrir ça va l'enrichir
alors je vous parle pas d'égalitarisme
surtout pas la française je vous parle
simplement d'une philosophie managériale
le deuxième ingrédient
eh bien c'est la possibilité à tous de
se réaliser par exemple que je puisse
travailler à mon développement personnel
me former construire mon parcours de vie
au sein de cette organisation
le troisième ingrédient garantir l'auto
direction faire que chacun dans
l'organisation quel que soit son rôle va
pouvoir prendre toutes les décisions
qu'il souhaite pour servir le projet de
l'entreprise sans avoir besoin de
l'autorisation d'un chef ou de répondre
à la procédure 414 et bien voilà c'est
ce regard ce regard positif que nous
allons essayer de poser sur nos
équipiers qui parfois va essayer de leur
permettre de se réaliser
parfois même de se révéler
pour que je réussisse a changé mon
regard il ait fallu moi d'abord que
j'allais regarder à l'intérieur de moi
grâce à mon coach jean loup et des
nombreux mois de travail j'ai pu
travailler mon lâcher prise j'étais
pétri de croyance je pensais par exemple
que si j'étais pas au coeur de la
bataille à prendre toutes les décisions
dans l'entreprise ils pouvaient rien se
passer de bien imaginer ce que j'ai pu
ressentir quand après un an de voyages
en famille autour du monde je reviens et
je rends compte je me rends compte que
l'entreprise marche mieux quand j'étais
là ça pique
j'ai pu apprivoiser ma vulnérabilité
quand je suis dans le doute je mets
inconsciemment en place des mécanismes
de contrôle très puissant qui
découragent souvent mes équipiers
j'arrive aujourd'hui à partager avec eux
cette difficulté
j'ai pu aussi découvrir ma part d'ombré
vous savez cette partie de chacun
d'entre nous cette partie qu'on passe
notre temps à essayer de masquer aux
yeux des autres
chez moi cette partie elle pourrait être
- abl que je ne le voudrais
elle pourrait même parfois avoir envie
de convaincre il de convaincre à tout
prix c'est peut-être même un mécanisme
qui est en train de se jouer en ce
moment entre vous et moi
et quand je nous emmène dans un voyage
incroyable mes voyages qui vont nous
permettre petit à petit de nous aligner
le cerveau le coeur et les tripes et
vous et vous où en êtes vous comment ça
se passe dans vos organisations sont
elles drivée par la défiance et la quête
de la performance individuelle ou bien
par la confiance et par la logique de
performance collective
face à ce constat qu'allez vous faire
allez vous décidez de changer de regard
sur vos collègues allaient décider où
allez-vous des poufs décidés à
travailler sur vous notre regard sur le
monde change le monde et nous pouvons
décider que ce regard sera positif alors
pour terminer je vais vous inviter à une
nouvelle expérience je vais vous
proposer de vous lever et de vous mettre
deux par deux avec quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas
je vais vous proposé d'inviter le
silence je vais vous proposé d'inviter
le silence et de fermer les yeux
je vous propose de faire le vide de vous
détendre puis lorsque vous sent très
près son tir est prêt je vous invite à
ouvrir les yeux à regarder la personne
que vous avez en face de vous dans les
yeux je vous invite à ce voyage est à
découvrir en elle tout ce qu'il existe
de positif alors bien sûr un petit peu
d'inconfort arrive
on va éviter les sourires et on va
prendre le temps de ce voyage découvrir
tout ce qui est positif dans les yeux de
l'autre
maintenant je vous invite à vous
connecter à l'autre en mettant vos mains
comme ceci
et je vous invite en quelques mots à
partager tout ce que vous avez vu de
magnifiques
c'est parti
mais
un grand bravo bravo manifs et
[Applaudissements]
vous avez pu le constater vous avez pu
constater la puissance de ce regard sur
l'autre alors maintenant je vous invite
à accompagner la naissance de ce nouveau
monde en lui accordant à regard positif
un regard transcendant un regard qui a
le goût des autres
merci
[Applaudissements]